Before we jump into those major scenes
that have been officially confirmed by
HBO let me first introduce you with
three new promotional photos that have
been released by the Spanish Game of
Thrones broadcaster today those new
photos featured Jon Snow in Winterfell
Daenerys Targaryen on Dragonstone and
Jaime and Cersei Lannister in the red
keep the nurse arriving for the first
time at Dragonstone and touching his
ground Jon's now walking to the halls of
inter foul as well as Cersei Lannister
and Jaime planning over their giant map
most likely belongs in the season
premiere additionally judging by John's
face expression this shot of aim will be
follow-up of the shot in which he
literally slammed little finger against
the wall okay let's now move on today's
topic as I already mentioned in the
beginning of this video today I'm going
to introduce you with major scenes that
are confirmed by HP itself a long time
ago it's been confirmed that your own
Greyjoy will come to King's Landing
after he is going to successfully defeat
your innocent snakes in the fleet battle
earlier this season and will make a deal
with the new Queen Cersei upon failing
to retake the Kingdom of the Iron
Islands from urine attempt which will
result in the deaths of Obara Nymeria
Illyria Sen and her daughter tyeen along
with Yara are going to get captured
meanwhile it's also important to
highlight that Jaime with Lannister army
along with sources only ally Randall and
his Tarly army who will become allies
earlier this season will get ambushed by
the nearest riding jørgen along with her
the Trekkie horde while they are
marching from Highgarden
after this defeat the only source is a
light our lists will pledge fealty to
House Targaryen violence our army will
not be powerful as it once had been a
response earth will be desperate their
enemies all around her enemies to the
east enemies to the west enemies to the
south enemies to the north her only Ally
will be lost which will represent a good
opportunity for urine to finally marry a
queen that's the moment in which urine
will come to King's Landing after his
successful defeats er along with the
sand snakes urine will come to King's
Landing and will parade with his
prisoners through its streets parading
all the way to the red keep which is the
residence of Queen Cersei and who pledge
his army along with his arm flee to
Cersei but in return search civil had to
marry him and make no mistake that's a
deal with Churchill except that's a deal
which will bring her hopes hopes that
her reign is going to last a little bit
longer the deal with Cersei knows she
has to accept or otherwise her reign is
over now this at this point already
confirmed event of the upcoming season
has also been confirmed by the official
trailer itself as I already said in my
breakdown on the official trailer
judging by the brief fluke of a person
that will clearly have a personal
meeting with Cersei and judging by the
following shot judging by Jamie's face
that person is definitely wrong Greyjoy
however as a confirmation that this
major scene really does include your own
Greyjoy offering his forces and
prisoners to serve seen the Great Hall
we have a shot from the recently
published video by the official game of
Thrones YouTube channel in that shot we
can see Lin ahead aid to us known as
Cersei Lannister and beyonds son to us
known as the mountain having a short
break on the set he might be confused at
this moment and they're probably
wondering how does this confirming a
major event of the upcoming season that
I've been talking about for the last few
minutes well if you look closely you can
notice a third actor that is portraying
a main character in Game of Thrones and
is clearly sharing a same scene with
them it's an actress that portrays
hilarious and and just as she was in
Chains seem bunch of leaked photos she's
also in Chains in this behind-the-scenes
shot confirming once again that your and
Cersei will make a deal will become new
allies deal which will most likely be
accompanied with a marriage at this
point I cannot confirm fate of your
Illaria and Tajin but in my opinion with
two sick villains that you're in Cersei
Muslim we are it's pretty easy to assume
that it will not end up well for them
especially for the sand snakes were most
likely going to be brutally tortured by
Cersei as revenge for killing her
daughter Myrcella whereupon they are
going to be executed so yeah we can
without a doubt expect to see a few
scenes of your in Cersei making a deal
in the Great Hall as well as a few
scenes of Cersei confronting imprisoned
delirious and another confirmed event of
the upcoming season that I will
introduce to within this video is Jon
Snow Sansa Stark along with other
northern Lords having a meeting in which
table the term fate of treasonous
northern houses I will ready briefly
introduced with this in my previous
videos so you might already know how
this has been confirmed a few days ago
same idiot that revealed Circe issuing a
scenes with imprisoned Illyria also
contained very interesting group shot in
Winterfell that includes Jon Snow Sansa
Stark
Brienne torment
northern Lords such as Lord Glover and
lady Mormont which at first glance is
not surprising at all since we already
know from the official trailer that we
will see this meeting probably in the
very first episode of the seventh season
however this same shot confirmed that
Jon Snow in northern Lords who most
likely have a meeting regarding fate of
the northern houses that betray them by
supporting the Bolton's this same shot
has also us again confirmed an
appearance of Ellis Karstark as you can
see an actress Megan Parkinson on the
right side as I said in previous video
appearance of Ellis Karstark in the
upcoming season is not that surprising
at all since Parkinson's agency has
actually confirmed her appearance in the
seventh season of Game of Thrones a few
months ago long story short Ellis
Karstark is daughter of Rickard Karstark
and is an heir of house Karstarks since
her father and two brothers died a long
time ago while her only remaining
brother Herald will either be executed
or sent to the wall for his betrayal
this meeting that includes King in the
north all northern Lords as veluz elyse
Karstark herself will the term fate of
her house which will most likely result
in Jon Snow's refusal to hold Ellis
responsible for her brother's betrayal
other than those events of the upcoming
season that here once again being
confirmed today I will also introduce
with a few exciting news about the
seventh season while we already knew
that season 7 premiere will run for 59
minutes yesterday HBO has revealed the
run times for each of the seven episodes
episode two and three will run for 59
minutes and 63 minutes which are the
longest second and third episodes in the
show's history on the other hand episode
4 is the shortest episode in the show's
history as it will only be 50 minutes
long episode 5 is the longest fifth
episode while episode six and the season
7 finale are longer than any episode of
the show yet produced the last two
episodes will break the record
established by the last third episode
the season 6 finale the winds of winter
which stood at 68 minutes episode 6 will
run for 71 minutes and the season finale
will be incredibly 81 minutes long
yesterday HBO Nordic uploaded a video
featuring some of the many locations
where the production filmed the season 7
with a focus on filming on ice
then los borrachos in spain in this
video everyone from the producers and
crew to main actors are talking about
having in Game of Thrones is and about
how impressive the filming location
sorry which is one of the main reasons
Game of Thrones is one of the best shows
there are a few interesting shots of
Iceland that features behind the scenes
look of a few main characters as we can
see Christopher cave do to us known as
Thurman is hanging out in Iceland with a
rope while I can tell for sure that
scenes filmed on this location monster
will represent the scenes beyond the
wall since Game of Thrones production
has used Iceland to stand in for lands
beyond the wall ever since the second
season now that you've been introduced
with two major scenes that have recently
been confirmed as well as with the
season 7 news let's get into another two
scenes that might have been confirmed a
couple of days ago apparently Toronto
Sun daily tablet newspaper got to learn
quite a bit about the production during
a set visit last October in fact runs on
details two scenes from two different
episodes that it's blogger still Tilly
directly witnessed as they reported
there will be a scene in the second
episode of the upcoming season that will
take place in the main hall in the
castle of Dragonstone to be exact around
its famous painted table carved in the
shape of Westeros and engraved with its
major cities and landmarks
apparently Daenerys Targaryen along with
Tyrion miss sandy Theon and yar Greyjoy
Ellaria sand and Olenna Tyrell will
discuss the best way to breakings
landing from Cersei Lancers grip the
newspaper described another scene that
will take place in the season premiere
in Winterfell according to Toronto Sun
there will be a meeting in Winterfell
that will attend obviously the king
himself Jon Snow as well as Sansa Stark
Brienne of Tarth Davos Seaworth Lyanna
Mormont and torment in this scene they
discussed the great war that is coming
about the threat of the White Walkers
and their whites whereupon Jon Snow and
says that they need to find out as much
of Syria and they can since it's the
only substance beside Valyrian steel
capable of killing White Walkers perhaps
this is the same meeting throughout
which they are going to determine fate
of treason and snortin houses and as
always let me know your opinion about
all of this in the comment section down
below I'm curious what your thoughts are
about
that sur scène urine will become allies
which will most likely be supported with
a marriage as as your thoughts about
three new promotional photos that I
introduced you with in this video I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
one peace